PROFESSOR: So our topic today
is the general question of
what sort of non-rational
persuasion is legitimate for a
government to engage in if we're
willing to accept the
kind of social contract
argument that we were
considering in the last few
weeks of the course.
So you'll recall that starting
with the account of justice
that's offered in Plato's
Republic, and continuing with
the account of the state of
nature that we get in Hobbes,
each of our authors has
suggested that it is in our
self interest, in a way that we
would reflectively endorse
governmental structures, to give
up some of our freedoms
in order to guarantee a certain
sort of stability.
But the sorts of constraints
that we considered in the
earlier discussions of this
concerned explicit laws.
They concerned ways in which we
contract into regulations
that we recognize as holding
upon us, and that we endorse
because we see the rational
reason for
contracting into them.
The argument that Hobbes makes
appeals to the notion of The
Prisoner's Dilemma, which is
a paradox of rationality.
It's a problem that arises when
self interests conflict
in particular ways and interact
with incentives in
particular ways.
What we looked at, at the end
of last lecture, and what
we'll look at in today's lecture
are the ways in which
human beings are complex.
They have, as we know from our
early lectures, not only
reason but also parts of their
soul which are affected by
things other than reason.
And that, too, turns out to
have implications for what
political structures
end up being
rational for us to endorse.
In particular, what we'll look
at in today's lecture, is on
the one hand Plato's argument
that in the ideal state there
would be rather radical
censorship of what sort of
fictional representations were
permitted, and Cass Sunstein's
argument that one of the duties
of the government is to
establish norms that affect
people implicitly in how it is
that they structure
their behavior.
So in the context of a lecture
on this topic it seems
appropriate to begin with
a couple of stories.
True stories about false stories
and their effects.
So in 1992, right around the
time when many of you were
being born, there was also born
on television a young boy
who was born to a television
character named Murphy Brown.
Now that's not in itself
newsworthy.
What is newsworthy is
that Murphy Brown at
the time was unmarried.
Indeed she didn't have
a long-term partner.
And the then-Vice President of
the United States, Dan Quayle,
famously gave a speech in San
Francisco in 1992 at which he
said, "Marriage is a moral issue
that requires consensus
and the use of social
sanction.
It doesn't help matters when
prime time television has
Murphy Brown, a character who
supposedly epitomizes today's
intelligent highly paid
professional woman, mocking
the importance of a father by
bearing a child alone and
calling it just another
lifestyle choice."
Now in fact Dan Quayle slightly
misrepresented what
happened on the show.
Murphy Brown, though she lacked
a long-term partner and
did bear a child without the
support of a second adult
figure, didn't call it just
a lifestyle choice.
But he was correct in that the
show did not go on to depict
in any way what the costs were
to Murphy Brown's life of
having to reconfigure her
life in a way that
she became a caregiver.
What's interesting, of course,
is that this is a real person,
Dan Quayle, the real Vice
President of the real country,
the United States of America,
calling into question the
imaginary birth of a child who
was not in fact the child of
the actress who played
Murphy Brown --
in such a way that he
saw it as eroding
values that are important.
Moreover, this debate hit the
news in an extraordinary way.
It was on the cover of Time.
It was on the cover of the New
York Post. "Dan rips Murphy
Brown." The New York Daily News
said, "Quayle to Murphy
Brown: You Tramp!" The New York
Times ran an article some
months later when, in an act of
enormous post-modern irony,
Murphy Brown the character on
television responded to Dan
Quayle the actual
Vice President.
And the New York Times offered
an article that began with the
paragraph, "Almost everyone
who watches television is
aware that Murphy Brown responds
tonight to Vice
President Dan Quayle, who helped
push family values to
the forefront of the 1992
presidential campaign by
criticizing the show's leading
character last spring for
having a child out of
wedlock." That's
story number one.
Here's story number two.
A little more recently.
In 2002 the television show 24
had depicting the President of
the United States a man
of African descent.
In 2007 that same show depicted
the President of the
United States as a woman.
In 2008, as all of you know, the
two leading candidates for
the presidential nomination in
the Democratic party were a
man of African descent
and a woman.
And the commentators who look
at elections, were commonly
saying things like this blog
from Newsweek says.
What it points out is that the
availability in fictional
representation of a character
who served as President and
was of African descent or who
served as President and was a
woman, played some role in
allowing actual citizens in
the real world--
not imaginary people on TV--
to have conceptual space
available for the possibility
of there being a President
of that kind.
Now Dan Quayle and the
commentators speaking about 24
were, as you know from your
readings for today--
channeling our friend Plato.
Dan Quayle essentially said,
if we want the guardians of
our city, that is the citizens
who are in a position to
govern and select leadership,
if we want the guardians of
our city to think that it's
shameful to be easily provoked
into hating another--
read: shameful to bear a
child out of wedlock--
"then we mustn't allow stories
about the gods," says Plato--
stories about attractive
characters on television says
Dan Quayle--
"warring or plotting against
one another." That is,
engaging in the activity
that we want to forbid.
So when Plato says "if we want
the guardians of our city to
think that it's shameful to be
easily provoked into hating
one another, we mustn't allow
stories about gods warring or
plotting against one another,"
he's making an argument that
Dan Quayle picks up on
2000 years later.
And to the extent that our
Newsweek commentators and
others in their discussion of
the 2008 presidential election
were pleased to see an opening
up of the range of candidates
who were being taken seriously
as potential leaders of this
nation, they too were channeling
Plato, who right
after the remark that we just
quoted, continues by saying,
"If we're to persuade our people
that no citizen has
ever hated one another and that
it's impious to do so,
then that's what should be told
in our story." That is
stories, fictional
representations, imaginary
experiences that become part of
the cultural conversation
can provide role models
that are both
problematic and inspiring.
Now the puzzle that this raises
if we think only in
terms of rationality
is the following.
How can something that we know
to be fictional affect our
actual behaviors
and attitudes?
It's not as if people watching
24 thought that David Palmer
was actually the president
of the United States.
It's not that people watching
Murphy Brown thought that the
character played by
Candice Bergen had
actually had a child.
People were profoundly aware
that these were fictional
representations.
And even young children are
remarkably good at separating
pretense from reality.
If you engage in an imaginary
tea party with a young child
where you pour imaginary tea
into a series of cups out of
an actually empty teapot, the
children are perfectly ready
to agree that the cups
are full in the
context of the pretense.
But no child who is thirsty
thinks that you can actually
get something to drink lifting
one of those up and bringing
it to your mouth.
If you engage in a game with a
child where you make cookies
out of Play Dough, children are
shocked and upset if you
actually try to bite into one.
And adults, too, have the
capacity to determine what's
merely imaginary and
what's actual.
Well they have the capacity with
one part of their soul.
The response to the puzzle
that gives rise to the
concerns that Plato and Dan
Quayle and our bloggers
articulate, is that the way that
fiction causes problems
is by affecting the non-rational
parts of the soul
in ways that are not easily
subject to rational regulation
or control.
Now this structure is already
familiar to us from our
general discussions of
parts of the soul.
We know from our lecture in
January that if I stand on a
glass surface above the Grand
Canyon and look down beneath
me and see the roaring Colorado
River, though my
rationality tells me that I am
safe, the non-rational parts
of my soul are affected by this
visual stimulus in a way
that causes me to tremble.
And even if I tell you and
convince you that what looks
to be a box of kitty litter is
in fact a box containing
chocolate cake covered with
coconut and Tootsie Rolls,
though the rational part of your
soul may believe me, it
has a rather difficult time
regulating the other parts.
So too in the series of puzzles
that we looked at in
the context of the heuristics
and biases tradition.
If I present you with a choice
where you're trying to get a
red ball between a bowl that
contains nine white balls and
one red one, or a bowl that
contains 92 white balls and 8
red ones, through the rational
part of your soul is
profoundly aware that you have
a 10% chance over here and an
8% chance over there, it is
nonetheless the case that if I
put you under cognitive load
in such a way that your
rational part isn't in a
position to make the decision,
you will be drawn towards the
bowl with more rather than
towards the bowl with
a higher proportion.
Reason isn't sufficient to
regulate the non-rational
parts of the soul.
And again in the context of our
discussion of temptation,
of weakness of the will.
Here's Ulysses tied
to the mast --
rationally committed to making
his way past the Sirens but
unable to do so without either
blocking his ears to prevent
himself from hearing the
temptation or tying himself to
the mast in such a way that
he's unable to act on it.
Plato says roughly this when
he identifies what it is
that's so problematic about
fictional representations.
He says, "the imitative poet
appeals to a part of the soul
that is inferior." Recall
Plato has the hierarchy
reason, spirit, appetite.
"He arouses, nourishes and
strengthens this part of the
soul and so destroys
the rational one.
He puts a bad constitution in
the soul of each individual by
gratifying the irrational
part of the soul."
So the fact that we know
something to be fictional with
the reason part of our soul
isn't sufficient to prevent it
from affecting us
in other ways.
In particular, Plato is worried
about three ways that
fiction can problematically
affect the soul.
And, importantly, willing
to forgive a fourth.
And looking through the details
of that will allow us
to get a better sense
of Plato's picture.
So what is it that Plato is
worried about when he's
worried about fiction's
capacity to affect the
non-rational parts
of the soul?
He's worried first of all about
that sort of thing that
Dan Quayle was worried about.
That observing a particular
circumstance in a fictional
representation and then
reasoning about it as an
available way of life may lead
to mischosen role models.
He's worried even more
profoundly when we observe
something in a fictional
context and because we
explicitly recognize it as
fictional, allow ourselves to
respond to it in a way different
than we would if it
were actual but such that
it affects us profoundly
emotionally in a way that
changes our attitudes of
approval or disapproval.
What he's not worried about--
and this will be crucial
to the larger
argument that I'm making--
is playful imitation.
Cases where not just at the
level of rationality, but also
with regard to the parts of
our response system that
aren't subject to rational
regulation, we engage with the
material somehow
at a distance.
There is available to us,
recognizes Plato, a capacity
for playful imitation.
And it's the contrast between
this and the fourth, the thing
that Plato finds most
problematic, that will help us
get to the heart of
Plato's picture.
Because what's most
problematic on Plato's picture--
and we'll give some contemporary
analogues of this
in a moment--
are cases where imitation of
imaginary figures plus
habituation to that mode of
behavior leads to what
Aristotle warns us so profoundly
against: a
misguided repertoire of
automatic responses.
So in order to make sense of
this rather subtle argument of
Plato, it's helpful for us to
take a step back and remember
where it is situated in
the argument of the
Republic as a whole.
So you'll remember that at
the very beginning of the
semester, back in January, we
started off by reading the
opening pages of book two of
Plato's Republic in which the
character Glaucon, in alliance
with his brother Adeimantus,
challenges Socrates to answer
the question, why
should we be just?
And Glaucon and Adeimantus
together present three kinds
of arguments, three kinds of
contentions in favor of the
view that justice is not
something that we engage in
for intrinsic reasons,
but only something that we
engage in because as a matter
of contingency it happens to
be instrumentally valuable.
Famously, Glaucon gives an
argument categorizing justice
into the kind of good that we
value only because of its
reputational benefits and goes
on to offer something like a
Prisoners' Dilemma analysis of
justice being everybody's
second-best choice.
He then presents a fictional
story --
the story of the ring of Gyges
followed by the story of the
pair of statues --
which is meant to persuade
in a different way.
And finally, Adeimantus points
out a continuity between
what's represented in the
context of the fictional
stories and what's represented
in the
context of common sayings.
Where does the argument
that Socrates
provides back then begin?
Does Socrates respond directly
to one and two and three?
To the three rather precise
arguments that Glaucon and
Adeimantus have presented?
No.
What he does is to introduce
the larger framework for
thinking about these questions,
the analogy between
the person and the city.
A discussion subsequently in
Book Two that we didn't read
of two kinds of cities
there might be.
And then ultimately in the
context of Book Four, he
introduces the three parts of
the city and the three parts
of the soul.
There he says that just as in
the ideal city there are
guardians and soldiers and
workers, so too in the
individual, there is reason,
spirit and appetite.
And you may remember back when
there was so much snow on the
ground that there was no way
to represent humanity other
than in the form of a snowman,
that we looked at this
parallel in some detail.
We looked at the way in which
the smallest directive part of
the soul is reason.
The middle is spirit.
The bottom is appetite.
And that corresponding to these
auxiliaries, soldiers
and guardians.
Now in order to see what's going
on in the discussion in
Books Three and Four that we
read for today about the
censorship of poetry and the
discussion in Book Ten about
the censorship of poetry, we
need to recognize something
really extremely interesting
about what happens
next in Book Two.
So remember, we have Glaucon's
challenge, why
should we be just?
And Socrates' rather bizarre
answer, which involves the
invocation of the city-state
analogy.
What happens next is that
Socrates goes on to provide an
account of how it is that the
guardians should be educated.
And the kind of education that
he is concerned with is the
education of the non-rational
parts of the guardians' soul.
What's going on here is Plato's
recognition that,
given the picture he has of the
state, just as "argument
alone," as Aristotle would say,
"is not enough to make
men good:" rather we must
cultivate in them certain
kinds of habits.
So too suggests Plato, by
putting the education of the
guardians immediately after the
discussion of the nature
and value of justice, so too
is it crucial in thinking
about the structure of the state
to think not only about
what laws look like--
that which regulates
by means of reason.
But also what non-rational
influences look like.
So, says Plato, turning to the
education of the guardians,
the very first question we
need to ask when we think
about what the ideal state looks
like is the question,
what does the early education,
the cultivation of appropriate
spirit and appetite in the
guardians look like?
And only once that is in place
are we in a position to turn
to that which is most valorized
by Plato in his
discussion, the cultivation
of reason.
So let's hear exactly
what Plato has to
say about early education.
And in pointing this out to you,
I want to remind you of
something that I mentioned last
lecture about the Nozick
and the Rawls.
You'll recall that I mentioned
to you that in the entire
index of A Theory of Justice
and in the entire index of
Anarchy, State, and Utopia,
there are two
references to children.
There are basically no
discussions of education,
whereas the very first thing
that Plato starts with in his
discussion of the ideal
state is this.
For the guardians, he asks, what
will their education be?
"You know, don't you, that the
beginning of any process is
most important.
Especially for anything
young and tender.
It's at that time that it is
most malleable and takes on
any pattern one wishes
to impress on it.
Shall we carelessly allow the
children to hear any old
stories and to take beliefs
into their souls that are
opposite to the ones we think
they should hold when they are
grown up?" And, this being
a Socratic dialogue, his
interlocutor says, "We certainly
won't." And Socrates
continues, "Then we
must first of all
supervise the story tellers.
We'll select their stories
whenever they are fine or
beautiful and reject them
when they aren't.
Nurses and mothers will shape
their children's souls with
their stories much more than
they shape their bodies with
their handling."
There was recently a
conversation about this
familiar character, Mister
Cookie Monster, who, in
keeping with remarks like the
one Socrates just made, began
singing songs like, "A Cookie
is a Sometimes Thing" and
began appearing in videos
about healthy foods.
It is the recognition that
early narratives play a
strangely formative role in the
attitudes of young people
that would lead to this
sort of change.
So Plato's first concern is
the one that I identified.
The idea that you will be
presented with a role model,
whom you will problematically
accept as a
reasonable way of existence.
When the poets tell stories,
he says, where "heroes do
terrible and impious deeds,"
these stories are harmful to
the people who hear them.
For "everyone will be ready to
excuse himself when he is bad
if he is persuaded that
similar things have
been done by heroes.
For that reason, we must put a
stop to such stories lest they
produce in youth a strong
inclination" to do bad things.
If it's available to you to
say, here's a character--
real or imaginary--
who behaved in a particular way,
says Plato, you are at
risk of viewing your behavior
through that light.
Even more dangerous, however,
is the fact it is possible
because of our complicated
relation to fiction, to
respond to something imaginary
in a way just different enough
to distort our experience but
just similar enough to affect
us implicitly.
"Listen and consider," says
Plato famously in Book Ten,
"when even the best of us hear
Homer or some other tragedian
imitating one of the heroes or
making a long lamenting speech
or beating his breast,
we enjoy it.
We give ourselves up
to following it.
We sympathize with the hero
and we take his suffering
seriously." And we do so, says
Socrates, even when that runs
counter to how it is that on
reflection we think we ought
to behave.
"When one of us," he continues,
"suffers a private
loss, you realize the
opposite happens.
We pride ourselves if we're
able to master our grief.
Is it right to look at someone
behaving in a way we would
consider unworthy and shameful
and enjoy and praise it rather
than being disgusted by it?" And
he goes through and runs
with another series of
emotions about this.
He says, just as we can do this
for sadness, so too we
appreciate in the context of
fiction buffoonish humor.
We appreciate in the context
of fiction certain kinds of
outrageous behavior.
But we are, he says, exactly the
wrong distance to be safe.
Our relation to fiction in this
regard is paradoxical.
On the one hand, there is
sufficient difference between
fiction and reality that we let
our emotions run loose.
Reason says: it's just
imagination.
It doesn't matter how
I respond to it.
This isn't reality.
This isn't reflective of who I.
Am But to the extent that
there is sufficient similarity
between the two cases, to the
extent that the distancing
happens only at the level of
reason, there is a risk
of contagion.
And we can see that perhaps most
profoundly by contrasting
the sort of cases that Plato is
worried about with the sort
of cases that he is
ostensibly not.
So in Book Three Plato concedes
that there are
certain contexts in which it
seems to be OK to engage with
imagination, to engage
with fiction.
He writes, when he-- he's now
speaking of the guardians--
comes upon a character unworthy
of himself, he'll be
unwilling to make himself
seriously resemble the
inferior character.
Rather, he'll be "ashamed to do
something like that unless
it is in play." And
it does seem--
and it's an extremely
interesting
fact about human beings--
that we are capable in some
contexts of taking a genuinely
play stance.
In my section, when I played
prisoners' dilemma games, the
poor freshman who played against
me-- who's seated here
in the third row--
didn't understand that I was
playing for play, which meant
that I was playing for real,
which meant that I defected
every single round.
And she lost a lot of money
and I gained a lot.
Now in so doing, it is my
sense that I had removed
myself from a domain where
contagion was a risk.
That not just at the level of
thinking about my engagement,
but even in the engagement
itself there was a sort of
ironic distance.
Some fictional representations
cause us to bear that to at
least part of their content.
In Monty Python, when you watch
Sir Lancelot chop off
the arms and then the legs of
the Black Knight, who is
leaping around bleeding,
it is not--
I take it-- the case that there
is even a small risk of
contagion to actual cases
of lost limbs.
But rather that a certain
kind of playful
stance is being taken.
At least that is until
it is disrupted.
I was, for very good reason,
taken to task on the feedback
page by one of the students in
this class for presenting
playfully in lecture, in the
context of our discussion of
punishment, an example of
somebody who aimed to shoot
somebody and failed or succeeded
at his aim on a day
after there had been a shooting
in New Haven.
Sometimes the reality that
surrounds a situation makes it
almost impossible --
because of the way in which it
permeates our non-rational
responses --
makes it almost impossible for
us to take a playful stance.
But the fact that we're able
to move in and out of this
attitude is, I think, one of
the most perplexing and
interesting facts about
human beings.
What's undeniable is that in
addition to being able to
engage in this sort of distant
imitation, this sort of
playful, non-habituating
copying, we are also capable
of engaging in imitation that
gives rise to habituation.
So, Plato writes, "Our guardians
must imitate from
childhood what is appropriate
to them." Namely, people who
are "courageous, self-controlled
and pious.
They mustn't be clever at doing
shameful actions, lest
from enjoying the imitation
they come
to enjoy the reality.
Or haven't you noticed that
imitations practiced from
youth become part of nature
and settle into habits of
gesture, voice and
thought?" Crazy?
Well, here's an article from
last week's New York Times
discussing the video
game Madden NFL 12.
Do any of you play
this online game?
Excellent.
So what is the feature of Madden
NFL 12 that struck the
New York Times as interesting?
It was this.
In the new version of Madden
NFL 12, a player who gets a
concussion is automatically
eliminated from play.
"Ever since the seriousness of
concussions became apparent on
the national scale," reads this
article from April 2,
"the primary message for young
football players -- if you get
a concussion get off the field
for the rest of the day--
has been one of the most
difficult for youngsters to
accept and execute.
That reality will soon be aided
by fantasy," -- it's
like it's channeling Plato --
"Madden NFL 12, the coming
version of the eerily
true-to-life NFL video game
played by millions of gamers,
will be realistic enough, not
only" it says, "to show
players receiving the
concussions, but also to show
that any player who sustains one
is sidelined for the rest
of the game, no exceptions."
So fantasy in the aid of
social regulation.
Here's another example.
How does the US military train
soldiers for the battlefield?
Some of what it does is
obviously to cultivate their
bodies in such a way that they
have the strength and stamina
to engage in certain
sorts of behaviors.
But one of the primary
modes of training is
through video games.
So here is a group of soldiers
playing a game that was
initially just used as a part of
a recruiting video for the
US army, a recruiting tool
called America's Army.
And subsequently got developed
into a training tool for
soldiers themselves.
Here's a group of soldiers
engaging
in video game practice.
And here's an article in
the Washington Post
from a few years ago.
"Virtual reality play prepares
soldiers for real war.
One blistering afternoon in Iraq
while fighting insurgents
in the northern town of Mosul,
Sgt. Sinkway Sualez opened
fire with his 50-caliber.
That was only the second time,
he says, that he ever shot an
enemy, a human enemy.
'It felt like I was in a big
video game,' he said. 'It
didn't even faze me,
shooting back.
It was just a natural
instinct.
Boom, boom, boom,' remembers
Sualez, a fast-talking
deep-voice, barrel-chested
29-year-old from
Chesterfield, Virginia.
He was a combat engineer in
Iraq for nearly a year.
And Sualez continues, 'the
insurgents were firing from
the other side the bridge.
We called in a helicopter
for an airstrike.
I couldn't believe I
was seeing this.
It was like Halo.
It didn't seem real.
But it was real.'"
And later in the article, the
reporter goes on to quote an
Army official from the office
of Defense Modeling and
Simulation who says, "The
technology in games has
facilitated a revolution
in the art of warfare.
When the time came for him"--
meaning Sualez--
says this officer, "to fire his
weapon he was ready to do
that and capable of doing it.
His experience leading up
to that time through the
on-the-ground training and the
playing of Halo and whatever
else, enabled him to execute.
His situation awareness
was up.
He knew what he had to do.
He had done it before or
something like it up to that
point."
So Plato's argument starts to
feel like it has some force.
What exactly does the
argument look like?
The argument that we've
been considering in
Plato runs as follows.
Plato suggests that fiction
affects the non-rational parts
of the soul in such a way that
they are potentially
disharmonious with the
rational part.
That is, fiction may cause us to
find appealing things that
on reflection we find
unappealing, or to find
unappealing things that on
reflection we find appealing.
It may, of course, also allow
us to cultivate things that
are in harmony with
our commitment.
Therapy can use exactly the
same techniques that video
game training in the Army does
to bring our non-rational
responses in line with
our rational ones.
But it is certainly a risk that
fiction will affect the
non-rational parts of the soul
in a way that renders them
disharmonious with the
rational part.
We, says Plato, reflectively
desire--
for all the reasons that we
discussed in the first part of
this course--
to have our souls, at least for
the most part, in harmony.
When we are not instinctively
reacting in ways that we're
reflectively committed to act,
it is costly to us and
undesirable.
But what we might think of as
the easy way out of this
problem, just saying to
ourselves, "it's only Halo,
it's only a video game," turns
out not to be sufficient.
Individuals, says Plato, even
the best of us, cannot
regulate these effects
internally
through our own reason.
We are not fully in control of
the parts of ourselves through
reason alone.
Instead, he says, it is possible
to regulate these
effects externally by letting
society make decisions for us
about what we are and
are not exposed to.
Consequently, in an argument
much like the one we see in
Hobbes, Plato is suggesting in
Book Ten that what rationality
requires, given our recognition
of limits that it
hits up against, is a
willingness to restrict our
freedom in certain ways.
Just as Hobbes argues that the
coordination problem to which
the Prisoner's Dilemma gives
rise, means that we need to
subject ourselves to a sovereign
who takes control
and enforces contracts, so too
does Plato suggest that we
need to subject ourselves to a
regulation by reflection of
aspects of experience that will
affect us in ways that
from a distance we know to be
dangerous, but from up close
we're unable to protect
ourselves from.
Now, that's not an easy argument
to take on board.
It raises all sorts
of questions about
who does the deciding.
It raises all sorts of questions
about whether
non-rational manipulation is in
fact the role of the state.
But it also reminds us that if
we are trying to think about
what political structures need
to look like for complicated
creatures such as ourselves,
there will, in the end, be no
easy answers.
And in next Tuesday's lecture,
I'll begin with what I'm going
to ask as the first question.
Which is, what does this have
to do with Sunstein?
But I will, in the meantime,
post the slides that are
associated with Sunstein so that
if you want to get a head
start on that second question,
about how non-rational
persuasion might happen in
society, you can take a look
at those over the weekend.
Thanks very much and I'll see
those of you who are not
visiting Bulldogs on Tuesday.